i'm really mad at big
he ruined our happy sad ending
mr big may have died at the end of the
first episode of the sex and the city
revival series and just like that
and just like that
they died
but spoiler alert he's still one million
percent a part of the current storyline
so this is your official spoiler warning
if you haven't watched yet
following big's funeral carrie says she
feels like she's in the home stretch of
grief at the will reading it's been a
rough few weeks
but
just keep reminding myself that at least
we were happy at the end
never been happier and just like that
something big happens turns out carrie's
late husband left one million dollars to
his ex-wife natasha
here it is one million dollars
what's all the drama what's the charity
[Music]
natasha when michael patrick king called
me he's like
do you think you want to i was like i
don't even care what you asked me to do
yes i will do it so yeah i was thrilled
of course fans of sex in the city will
recall that carrie was partially
responsible for the end of big's
marriage to natasha after she caught the
two having an affair in her house
carrie
i see you
wait
i knew you were having an affair but not
in my house
at the time carrie was cheating too on
her then boyfriend aiden
i never meant to hurt you
i know
but i did
flash forward to present day kerry who
meets with her besties miranda charlotte
and stanford to discuss the new
development
you know what it's not even about the
money it really isn't i would be just as
upset if i if i found out that he left
her ten dollars but just
why is she in there at all and cue
carrie obsessing over getting answers on
the status of biggs relationship with
natasha
so what else don't i know
carrie emails big's ex then dms her on
instagram only to get blocked so carrie
shows up unannounced at natasha's work
after seeing her enter the building only
to be told natasha is away in rome
i'm really mad at big
i almost forgot how i used to feel all
those years ago you know so nervous and
insecure and desperate
you know like what we had wasn't enough
like i wasn't enough
and i just hate that after all the good
years this is what i'm left with
he ruined our happy sad ending
kerry later has an awkward run-in with
natasha in a coffee shop bathroom and
finally gets some closure turns out the
exes haven't seen each other since their
divorce and natasha was just as much in
the dark as carrie
classic john just always a puzzle
at least with me
i'll never understand why he ever
married me when he was always in love
with you
when etie caught up with bridget
moynihan who plays natasha at the show's
premiere she opened up about joining the
revival series and how different it felt
all these years later you know what the
first year i did it i was like
bambi in the city
fresh off the boat
never done anything before and was you
know literally thrown into the mix of
sex in the city so i was nervous didn't
know what i was getting into
now i know
and i have a few more you know years
under my belt here and i was just but i
i i was on set like a fan almost like oh
my god i can't believe i'm back this is
so great seeing the fashion
seeing the girls together and playing
together it was so much fun but back to
carrie
we felt excited about
the kind of stories that we were
interested in telling we were curious as
to you know about where they were and
who they were and what was their life
like and who were they now surrounded by
she decides that the will money was
big's way of apologizing to natasha for
cheating on her and ending their
marriage on such terrible terms and
while fans may still be reeling from
big's death
i love that people are upset it means
they care the show's creator michael
patrick king told et his death was
important for the story line of the new
series
i wanted
to see
if it is better to have loved and lost
than never to have loved at all but
really
also the thesis of the show has always
been the most significant challenging
relationship of all is the one you have
with yourself and if you have that and
then somebody else comes along well
that's fabulous so this is now the
significant challenging relationship of
her life
is the one you have with herself
[Music]